quelle réponse peut apporter la grande
distribution ses problèmes de pénurie de
flambée des prises alimentaires n'en
parlent avec vous Didier diopan bonjour
bonjour président du Groupement les
Mousquetaires Intermarchés numéro 3
français de la grande distribution à
notre sujet aujourd'hui c'est une
inflation des produits alimentaires
inflation qui est de 10% selon l'INSEE
pour l'expliquer évidemment l'évoquer
pendant l'émission il y a la guerre en
Ukraine il y a la sécheresse et la
matière première il y a les coups de
production il y a les salaires mais il y
a aussi une autre raison et je vais en
parler avec vous c'est ce bras de fer
entre la grande distribution et
l'industrie agroalimentaire on va te
faire qui n'est pas qui n'est pas né
d'hier est-ce que quelque part la
distille les distributeurs comme vous
portent une part de responsabilité dans
cette inflation des produits notamment
alimentaires nous portons une
responsabilité forte dans la limitation
de cette inflation c'est évident si nous
n'étions pas là si nous n'arrivions pas
à discuter si nous faisions pas peser
par exemple aussi les usines qui sont
les nôtres en France pour nous
approvisionner nous serions en effet
otage d'un certain nombre de grands
groupes qui qu'en fait le choix de
sortir de vos de des référencer c'est le
thème approprié les eaux du groupe
Danone c'est parce que vous estimez
qu'ils ont gonflé de manière injustifiée
disproportionnée les prix c'est ça la
vraie raison oui c'est ça la vraie
raison bien sûr il y a un certain nombre
d'industriels celui-là on la cité Danone
mais mars par exemple sur ces barres
chocolatées a décidé que la France était
un pays qui n'était pas assez rentable
au niveau mondial donc il a mis
pratiquement tous les grands
distributeurs français mais libre à vous
de ne pas suivre
les livrons pas sauf à accepter des
hausses de tarifs donc nous ne les
acceptons pas et ça pose évidemment des
difficultés d'approvisionnement alors
comme CAO n'est pas cultivé en Ukraine
comme vous le savez comme vous Michel
dans Leclerc dénonce des hausses
suspectes encore une fois de prix
pourtant il y a ce rapport d'information
du Sénat qui a de juillet qui rejette
ses accusations et qui dit que les
hausses de prix seraient justifiées du
fait de l'inflation qu'est-ce que vous
répondez là d'abord c'était en juillet
ensuite la réponse
sans moins d'une semaine nous a paru un
petit peu hâtives et sûrement
n'envisageait pas ce que serait la suite
de l'évolution des cours des matières
premières de ces produits et de
l'inflation en général sans doute comme
nous tous par ailleurs
on imaginait que le conflit serait
peut-être de courte durée que dès la
rentrée venue
tout s'arrangerait ça n'est pas le cas
bien évidemment donc tout ça c'est la
faute des du secteur agroalimentaire
il y a secteur agroalimentaire les
grands industries de centaines de
milliers de PME performantes qui font
attention
ce sont des grands certains noms de
grands groupes pas tous non plus là
dedans on a tiens on prenait l'exemple
des barres chocolatées tout à l'heure
nous avons des demandes d'augmentation
de 1 sur une échelle de 1 à 3 nous
pensons que celui qui demande trois fois
plus que l'autre doit avoir les mêmes
coups de fabrique pas la rémunération de
ces partenaires par aimant libre à vous
de ne pas augmenter les prix aussi
ne pas augmenter les prix cette loi
égaline nous y contraint d’abord elle
nous contraint à prendre une marche
minimum sur les produits vous savez que
si on modifie cette loi nous pourrions
demain dans nos magasins baisser les
prix de 10 % sur les produits du courant
ce qu'on appelait les produits d'appel
les produits d'usage qu'on des
consommateurs donc ça on pourra le faire
on ne peut pas le faire et nous n'avons
aucun droit de revente à perte donc nous
sommes contraints si nous acceptons les
hausses de prix de ces industriels de
monter également les prix dans nos
magasins mais quand vous retirez des
produits des rayons quelque part il y a
une vous portez une part de
responsabilité dans cette pénurie faut
se mettre à la place du client il est
privé du produit qui voulait acheter
c'est plus cher il pourrait se sentir
pris en otage en cette guerre entre
certains encore une fois garçon merci
entre l'industrie et agroalimentaire les
grands acteurs et puis l'agrand
distribution les les clients qui sont
les nôtres et les citoyens en général ce
sont plutôt reconnaissants de mener
cette bataille alors oui c'est compliqué
oui parfois quand on est habitué à
utiliser telle ou tel produit tel ou
pour tel biais pour le biberon etc ça
présente des difficultés et c'est aussi
un inconvénient pour nous parce que une
partie de ses clients va les faire c'est
les achats en question chez nos
concurrents et nous nous assumer on
assume ça nous paraît être notre devoir
de dire non quand il y a vraiment des
situations d'abus vous pourrez enterrer
l'âge de guerre avec Danone ou d'autres
la discussion est toujours en cours ou
la ligne rouge interrompt bien
évidemment là je veux dire parce que
nous
avec comme dans toute négociation des
concessions de part et d'autre mais pour
ramener vous savez qu'on a la
connaissance et d'ailleurs la loi egalim
en question est intéressante pour ça
nous avons la connaissance des matières
premières agricoles et du prix
qui contribue à la fixation nous avons
la connaissance des la première
industrielle nous les connaissons d’être
mieux que nous avons nos propres usines
donc on sait ce que c'est que l'énergie
on sait ce que c'est que le transport on
sait ce que c'est que les machines et
combien ça coûte de les utiliser nous
avons une parfaite connaissance tant que
ça ne rentrera pas n'en a juste
rémunération des agriculteurs quand il
s'agit de produits agroalimentaire et ce
que nous connaissons de l'évolution des
prix de nos usines tant que ça ne
rentrera pas nous ne rentrerons pas les
produits dans nos magasins bon on a
parlé du déréférencements mais il y a
aussi un autre phénomène en ce moment je
le dis à l'anglaise c'est la shrink
flashon c'est en gros des industriels
qui augmentent leur prix ou les
stabilisent mais qui réduisent la
quantité des produits qui sont à
l'intérieur est-ce que vous l'avez
constaté dans vos enseignes est-ce que
vous acceptez quand même de vendre ces
produits en 1980
nous avons inventé nous avons créé nous
avons lancé quelque chose qui a été
repris d'ailleurs deux ans après par la
loi les prix au litres et les prix au
kilo
1980 pourquoi parce qu'à l'époque déjà
il y avait les mêmes tentations le bidon
de 5 litres devenait un bidon de 4
litres et demi ça a toujours existé
depuis 5 ans et que les industriels
quand les coûts augmentent ou quand on
désire de gagner un petit peu plus de
sous augmentent quand les actionnaires
font pression
et bien il y a une tentation de diminuer
un petit peu la sensibilisation le grand
mage c'est arrivé à tout temps c'est
c'est pas la grosse partie des produits
mais ça arrive et on a toujours lutter
contre ça mais c'est pas un API
phénomène quand on écoute le NG foot
watch qui demande au patron de la grande
distribution de s'engager on a le patron
de Système U qui a condamné mais sans
prendre d'engagement le Clair condamne
aussi ce que vous aussi vous pourriez
prendre ici des engagements des mesures
concrètes pour limiter ou en tout cas
empêcher ce phénomène évidemment on nous
condamnons les industriels abusent de
trop par exemple si la portion de 100 g
devient 80 g et qui reste au même prix
ça veut dire qu'on augmente les prix de
20% et ça c'est pas possible et ça c'est
des référencesments avant de se quitter
cette question quelle réponse peut
apporter la grande distribution face à
séance de prix qui sont à deux chiffres
sur l'alimentation comment on aide les
ménages à continuer à de remplir leur
caddie il faut quoi plus de promotion
plus de remises des prix bloqués
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire nous avons
mis en place une gamme de plus de 500
produits 650 exactement pour être sûr
qu'il y en a au moins toujours 500 de
présents dans les magasins même si
parfois il peut y avoir des ruptures à
moins d'un euro
ça par exemple c'est un travail qu'on a
fait on s'est battu et c'est pris un
restaurant bloqués pour plusieurs mois
pour cette année tous ces 650 produits
restons en dessous d'un euro on fait le
maximum de promotion qui nous est
possible et consommation en sont très
friands et puis nous allons continuer à
mener ces combats pour quitter
aussi l'image de la grande distribution
à regarder non les mars de la grande
distribution ont déjà bien souffert il
faut savoir que le résultat moyen d'un
distributeur c'est entre 1 et demi et
deux et demi pour ça c'est là que ça se
joue donc une fois qu'on a déjà investi
ce qui est le cas près de la moitié dans
les prix pour retarder
c'est hausse il va pas y avoir grand
chose à gratter donc voilà merci de
passer nous voir Didier diopan président
du Groupement les Mousquetaires
Intermarché merci à vous merci
[Musique]